I'm envisioning you as like a
19-year-old girl going to Nashville and
let's face it you were extremely
attractive a very good-look woman were
men constantly hitting on you so like
they probably looked at you like oh look
at this rube this 19-year-old girl from
Tennessee did they try to take advantage
of you not only in business but sexually
as well uh well I was 18 when I moved to
Nashville I met my husband the first day
I got there so I kind of I had left two
boyfriends back home thinking the last
thing I want in Nashville as a boyfriend
so what's the first thing I do find one
but I never thought of it men flirted
with me but I was a flirt myself and I
never took it wrong because you got to
remember I had six brothers and my dad
and my uncles and I love men there's
only been like a couple of uncomfortable
moments but I think anybody would would
have those it's just somebody not maybe
taking you as serious as you are until
you really make them know hey I'm
serious here knock it off you know so I
didn't have have the same problems I was
sure who I was and I always I've often
said even before Steve Harvey said it
I'd said in interviews that I look like
a woman but I think like a man there
were guys like who in business who would
say Hey you know this before your Dolly
part in the Superstar like hey you want
to uh record for me listen you know quit
proquo come out to dinner with me and
let's have a couple of drinks and all
this kind of thing that that wasn't your
experience no uh but there was always
let me just say this I never slept with
anybody to get ahead to get from point A
to point B if I slept with somebody it's
because I wanted to not because I was
doing it for any reason other than just
something you know that I wanted to do
but of course you get all that but like
I say I was pretty sharp too I was
pretty clever and knowing the nature of
men and understanding that if I was
going to dress like I dressed and look
like I looked I would have been
disappointed if somebody hadn't noticed
me or you know have paid attention to me
the whole Dolly look the whole Persona I
find fascinating you saw the town
whatever they called her back then the
town or something the and
you said to yourself wow that's an
outrageous look I'm going to dress like
that and your grandpa did he hit you or
something because of the way you were
dressing what did he do well my grandpa
was just always preaching to me you know
looking like he would just call me jez
Bell and uh which I love my grandpa he
was great but he would always say don't
you want to go to heaven and my famous
line is that I would say I would get
smacked around just for sassin you know
I'd say something like yeah I want to go
to heaven but do I have to look like
hell when I get there or a song and then
you got to get you you know like
backhanded or something but uh that's
natural though I think for kids cuz I
was pretty outgoing and I just knew how
I was going to look that DD daddy
couldn't whip it out of me Mama couldn't
talk it out of me and Grandpa couldn't
preach it out of me I was going to look
the way I looked and I still do because
that's how I felt can I ask you this how
old were you when Dum blonde came out I
was actually uh 19 when I recorded that
but I did not write that song that was
written by curly Putman as was Fred
Foster at Monument Records who I was
working with at the time he had him
write a song for me and that was it
things I wrote I wish I had but it does
say everything that I feel just because
I'm blonde don't think I'm
dumb yeah just because I'm blonde don't
think I'm dumb it's such a great song
it's like okay give me a break this was
my first top 10 record and never went to
one I don't think it was in the top 10
and but that was my first chart record I
mean you must have been on Cloud9 now
you've been on the radio for puppy love
you put out dumb blonde and now you're
in the top 40 you know that's pretty
incredible that's a journey that you go
through when you go but then Dum blond
was kind of like the start of of my
bigger
career